shoot a three-point shot
stevenson for three
and he strums his guitar right away
had not made a three in his previous two
games
[Applause]
he's coming down the defense didn't get
to him
and that's what the people remember from
his previous two stints he will strum
the guitar if he does something well
first three of the year
for lance stevenson he played six games
in atlanta on a 10-day hardship contract
when that expired he signed a 10-day
hardship contract with the pacers the
team that drafted him back in 2010.
[Applause]
a product of lincoln high school in
brooklyn new york last night he played
his 300th game in a pacers uniform at
madison square garden and ironically his
first game back
is against his hometown
[Applause]
team got to be the clock and equipment
i mean
it's 21 seconds on the shot clock so
that appears to be correct so would it
be the game clock but i think they feel
comfortable that they've got that
corrected james where mills fakes like
he's gonna set a screen sprints out
and he'll shoot a three-point shot
stevenson for three
and he strums his guitar right away not
a great three-point shooter but he was
wide open only his seventh of the year
stevenson fires again
his intent was to come down and do
something offensively you can see harden
is really late if almost non-existent
miles turner
acknowledging that he had overrun
and got to run away from august
james johnson wants a piece of stevenson
goes inside with a left hand nine in the
quarter for stevenson